okay in our top story today the u.s has
overtaken china as the biggest hub of
bitcoin mining no surprise uh we all
know that china has had enough of
cryptocurrency they're obviously going
to have their own sovereign you know
ecash crypto equivalent and they do not
want to give up their currency to a
bunch of randos uh building a
distributed network that nobody controls
big shocker there an authoritarian
country with a million people in a gulag
slash
at its worst uh potentially a modern day
concentration camp uh yeah they they
don't want to give over their money
supply hmm fascinating didn't see that
coming
so anyway in an article published this
morning in the financial times uh
research by cambridge center of
alternative finance i don't know what
that is the research showed that china's
share of the global hash rate fell from
44 to zero
we read that correctly between may and
july of this year remember hashrate
that's the computational power
that uh is used to basically create uh
bitcoin and
you know it uh measures the amount of
guesses per second that miners are using
to decode the blocks you can read the
original white paper more guesses per
second the larger the hash rate and in
comparison to china the u.s share of
global hash rate more than doubled from
17 to 35
from april to august and you know that
the ccp the chinese communist party
remember the communist in there that ban
i think started in may
and they said environmental and
financial concerns it's really more
about control
and we covered that back on episode 1220
and 1235 as it was happening and in that
story uh we covered actually that three
tons of bitcoin mining rigs were shipped
from china to maryland
and uh you would have to ask yourself is
this a good or a bad thing for
bitcoin and is it a good or bad thing
for the people of china and is it a good
or bad thing for the democracies in the
west well just comparing these two
charts um here's the hash rate from
september 2019 china had over 75 percent
the u.s had just four percent
and uh basically china had a monopoly
and they gave it away
which is really interesting you fast
forward 23 months and if you're watching
our youtube you can see that the hash
rate from august 20 21 almost two years
later the us now has 35 to china as i
said earlier has zero
and um
you can see now that uh there's a nice
distribution across other nations
romania canada other places ireland
everybody's getting a little piece of
this so
obviously this is better for bitcoin
because having an authoritarian country
controlling the majority or a
significant amount of
the network is horrible and
leads to a lack of trust
in fact there was a lot of thought that
the russians or the chinese might have
been behind bitcoin that is a conspiracy
theory that many people have floated and
it's used to destabilize the us dollars
so think about it
if you were russia or you were china and
you wanted to destabilize the dollar how
would you do that well if you made a
global
uh currency that had a finite supply and
that had all these great features that
it could be shared anywhere and just
basically had all the qualities of a
cryptocurrency versus a print currency
it could be tracked
but not perfectly tracked and
you win by it making the us dollar less
of the standard right the fact that the
us dollar is the standard is really good
for america and if bitcoin can challenge
that that would be good for who who is
it good for if the us loses power
it's really good for russia because
as we'll hear in our interview after
this brief news with jacob
russia's goal is to make
other countries look bad and make their
societies look dysfunctional so that
their citizens don't look inward and say
wow russia sucks it sucks to live here
putin is horrible these uh the way we're
living is terrible i'd rather live in
america i'd rather defect they don't
want you to think that way and the same
is true to a lesser extent uh for china
although china doesn't seem to look at
us um
as a viable alternative for their
citizens to defect to but china will
fully release a digital remnb is my
prediction and uh they'll control that
currency and as we talked about those
fed coins are going to give even more
power to china so
what china was faced with was people
who were either corrupt or great
business executives uh great
entrepreneurs taking their money
putting it into bitcoin and leaving
china right that's what everybody was
trying to do in china who had any kind
of money it's just how do i get this out
of china well with a fed coin if you
were to leave china or let's say you
were jack ma who supposedly is now i
read in the news
showing up for meetings in hong kong uh
potentially uh going to make a big
splash and and be more public again uh
we'll see
but suppose he's taking business
meetings according to sources in the
news well
you went from people being able to use a
currency that nobody controlled and now
you have a currency that you have more
control over than chinese dollars or say
diamonds or gold or
you know whatever you happen to be able
to smuggle out of the country
so this is going to be like a double win
for china and it's obviously a terrible
thing for
democracy i think conversely you know
bitcoin is really terrible for the us
dollar if bitcoin becomes the standard
and the us loses
uh the power of the dollar that's going
to be very very bad for america
conversely it would be very good for the
citizens of china and it was very good
because they could get their money out
of the country and have some sovereignty
and
not be under the control of
the chinese communist party so
now
the chinese communist party is going to
take even more control which is their
want and we're going to be talking about
that with our guest today on the program
it's time for another r crowd deal of
the week right now you can join our
crowd's investment in orient according
to the deal memo rn software only indoor
gps is 20 times more accurate and
scalable than current solutions and
they've landed contracts with some of
the biggest retailers in the world so
why join our crowd well our crowd
investors were in early on some of the
best performing ipos of 2019 and 2020
and now you can join them with our crowd
accredited investors can invest directly
easily and most importantly early our
crowd investors have benefited from
companies ipo'ing like beyond me or
being bought by companies like intel
nike microsoft oracle and my personal
favorite uber so here's your call to
action our crowds accredited investors
have already invested over one billion
dollars in growing tech companies if
you're an accredited investor you can
join our crowd for free at
our
crowd dot com slash twist and review all
the current deal memos there's no
payment involved until you decide to
invest
that's ourcrowd.com
twist to sign up for free